louis de funès qui se rasent louis de
funès que l'on bonbonnes car il va
tourner piti piti pas de serge corbère
cette fois il est directeur d'une troupe
de danseuses et ils dansent lui même
tout en se préparant le numéro un du
comique français nous disent ce qu'ils
pensent du rire au cinéma beaubien une
bonne tête de victimes
même pas une tête de mort aussi de
rachat place et c'est une chose
précédent les seules choses des seuls
monuments religieux mac est restée seule
chose qui reste on notera ça reste assez
est resté seul à s'y intéresser une
heure mais lui ça c'était une chaussée
paris
buster keaton et bien sûr et à la gaîté
fabuleux aussi c'est dur a décerné des
prix évidemment on peut questionner plus
à chaplin d'impôt compris mes valeurs et
les redites et fabuleux séduire les
premiers mois j'étais un peu
impressionné aussi dans le temps car
mike berry impressionné comme acteur
j'ai vu et bien impressionné beaucoup
par hardy j'ai même passé à une autorité
et c'est donc je ne serais pas du tout
j'ai commis les injures et arriva
faisait beaucoup plus rire que laurel &
maintenance échanges et me font rire à
égalité vous les voyez souvent les
chapelains les autres noms mais je me
suis acheté un top petits films de
laurel et hardy le chaplin
ce projet de ça dans la salle à manger
et on apporte beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
à faire
souvent la critique dit maintenant
chaplin se sait ce que c'est douloureux
ce poids lourd du tout c'est un énorme
gigantesque comique qui de temps en
temps mais il fait tout notre tendresse
mais si on écoute certains critiques
c'est triste d'en but à l'automne il je
suis surpris à des gens qui vont voir un
chat [ __ ] qui plombe
pas moi je ne pleure pas je ris énorme
mais je suis tout le temps à la
recherche du grand film donc tous les
films que j'ai faits qu'on a fait me
semble déjà périmé fini je suis pas
comme sérieux donc la pression de ce
périlleux reçus jeudi matin ce but on
avait l'impression qu'ils regardent avec
plaisir je les regarde avec plaisir mais
c'est le nouveau du matin qu'il ya
tellement à faire en nous je note aussi
dans lesquelles j'ai tourné eu deux sens
le premier c'était une ouverture de
porte
je vois une pause dans la progression de
barbizon il y avait là t il pas fait ils
ont fermé la porte avec une petite mine
comme ighirri ce soit comique pays
restait lippi comme tourner ça s'arrête
à 7h30 et ce délit était il était 7h bas
alors j'essaye de jaune choses comme il
y en a qu'on perd sa danseuse et c'était
c'est sûrement très mauvais mois si
j'aime ça simplement
[Musique]
aimer vos débuts
non parce que j'étais obligé obligé d'en
faire parce que j'ai commencé avec le
théâtre alors le cinéma recherché
puisque c'est le même moyen d'expression
face avant c'est un moyen d'expression
dramatique aussi
à 90 ans et je me sers du tout je sais
ce qui me plaît je aussi juste si je lis
un scénario je sais qu'il me plaît mais
je suis professeur du tout me suis déjà
penché sur la chose mais rien ne sort
ces quelques gags c'est tous pour votre
position vous êtes le numéro un on a un
écrit partout vous êtes le numéro 1 du
cinéma français
qu'est ce que ça vous fait ou home écrit
des choses
seul un juge peut réellement se passer
dans les gendarmeries gants une cinq ou
six effet bourgi évidemment c'est une
grande aventure une aventure
merveilleuse de jeu avec bourvil et ça
c'est pendant votre fleur je n'ai qu'une
hâte c'est de retourner j'aimerais bien
jouer par exemple un rôle dans how légal
avec j'aimerais bien jouer avec elle à
bruz je me levais la halle en ce moment
j'en cherche quelque chose avec
fernandel mais on trouve rien c'est le
scénario tu repars et gris avec bourvil
et uri alors ce sera quoi sage en six
séances
et ce sera quoi un film d'époque l'autre
à billets qui ferait ça faisait encore
ça promet vous aimez vous déguiser non
pas du tout ma faim le cinéma c'est de
cette prof du comédien finalement vous
avez vu pas mal de films en costumes ne
sais pas j'ai fait là
dans la reine margot je faisais ruggeri
l'empoisonneur vous direz avec françoise
rosay qui était très très charmante
lorsque dans ce film là ils me
connaissent ils étaient logés un tout
petit rôle trois jours à faire me coller
systématiquement de dos et quand j'étais
pas de dogme était un petit machin qui
faisait qui repend voyez ça cache la
lumière est toujours sept ans doit la
force rose est intervenue et d'écouter
mes enfants me voient prendre une heure
et demie 20 1h30 lescure vous qu'on voit
quand même des faits laisse un petit peu
était très charmante et on a commencé
quand à vous voir avec motivé le film
kérity a démarré on a vu vraiment si de
funès moi j'ai progressé petit à petit
tout le temps comme au théâtre
mais pas un film qui a fait dans les
grands marchés aussi j'ai voulu parce
que j'ai voulu par exemple j'ai commencé
avec j'avais deux francs 50 c'est à dire
de francs 50 de l'époque 950 le premier
cachet est le 2 le deuxième j'ai dit
combien tu gagnes pas judith de
transfert envie de m'écouter
nous devons donner 3 francs quand même
et j'ai trois fronts puis après j'ai
toujours toujours j'aimerais rester dans
le cadre toujours augmenter même d'une
marche i a rien à faire et je monte pour
moi pour mon plaisir
le monde de rôle aussi bien entendu mais
ça fait beaucoup de marge maintenant oui
mais s'ils ont l'air dégringole ça fait
beaucoup de mal mais je crois pas non je
dis ça profanes qui mon esprit qui est
pas bon d'ailleurs vous lancer mateja
une chose qui m'intéresse c'est de faire
de bons films c'est tout autre chose
parlons un peu de celui là qui s'appelle
le mort qui s'appelle le mort castrés
n'ont ni s'appellera piti piti pas c'est
le piti piti pas c'est une a jugé un
petit pas le l'aide peut-être chez pas
c'est françois de roubaix qui les écrit
notre musique on a bien de la chance et
il a un morceau de dent qui revient
souvent dans l'ue et août et les
danseuses des épidémies liban dans la
danse si c'est bon oui est ce que l'on
triche beaucoup des couches souvent
lorsque vous voyez un film de de funès
ouvriers pas du tout mais je sens si ça
va être bien aux pages 206 a des chances
d'être bien
si vous faites un brûlot might want me
sens comme vous trouvez les gars quand
voulait répéter brouillé quand même
henry entre nous parce que c'était un
peu comme une fête 27 creuset où on
fabrique ça avec bourvil en rit
énormément avec gabin cabane il a fait
des bons fous rires
[Musique]